[Music]
it is ferocious relentless and it's
still spreading across 18 000 acres but
those battling these blazes are making
progress a quarter of the fires are now
contained
[Applause]
in the nearby town of merced 8 am is
rush hour
the roads are gridlocked but with fire
engines
these commuters are heading to an
altogether more dangerous workplace
among the 3 000 firefighters on this
vast operation battalion chief jeremy
snyder
his team are preparing to spend an
uninterrupted 24 hours on the front line
the fatigue sets in you don't get very
many days off
it's mentally and physically challenging
he has been in the job for 25 years and
has noticed a shift we are having
rapid growth of fires extreme fire
behavior that we normally don't see
until later in the fire season in
september and october we expect
most fires to grow very rapidly and
with that it'll also deplete resources
this team are in a race against time to
protect the homes of people like
jacqueline and peter who've been
evacuated you work your whole life you
know to accomplish something
and then that's all you have
to go there
to think that
something like this can take it in a
matter of seconds and it's hard
it's really hard
the drive into the evacuated area is
silent
just a few days ago this was green
woodland
but the change now is dramatic at first
for a split second it almost feels like
a winter scene
because there are no leaves on the trees
and they have this
slightly white gray color but of course
that's not snow
it's ash and this isn't winter
it's the height of summer
and even away from the front line the
physical repetitive work continues
we're trying to make it cold so we can
hopefully
repopulate the people again
this fire has not just ripped through
forests but buildings and livelihoods
this is the human cost of wildfires
homes and belongings utterly destroyed
there is nothing left to salvage and why
would you rebuild a life here when this
could happen
all over again
extreme weather has become increasingly
common
the aftermath of the oak fire is a
hostile desolate landscape and the
threat is far from over joe pike sky
news mariposa california